plato's great discovery was just as
groundbreaking as it was momentous with his
ideas he can be said to have shaped the
entire occidental culture his name
is known all over the world more than
2000 years ago
platten expressed a tremendous suspicion in his allegory of the cave
that people saw
many shadows on one  high wall and
keep these shadows for real
figures with this parable plato wanted to
shake his contemporaries awake
no longer stay in a
manipulated illusory
world without recognizing the true world
the athenians would let themselves be blinded by material
pleasures wealth and demagogic
politicians and plato is
suspected right now  today in the digital
age year amazingly up-to-date
we don't all run the risk of losing
cellphones and television in media
shades and projections through the internet in
order to recognize the truth so
plato the human being has to learn
to see with the inner eye we are in the
he says he is able to feel the truth if
he succeeds in looking behind the
mere appearances
because behind
everyday objects and the visible
world there is a second invisible
reality, a higher scientific level
that can reveal the true world to us,
this second reality is, according to Plato,
the realm of  ideas in particular the
idea of the good, true and beautiful that we ca
use a
a guide what exactly are these ideas where do they
ome from and what does plato mean when he speak
of the good itself yes i hav
tried to answer all these questions in the book flat and in 60
minutes  and i
have
tried to make plato's fascinating world of ideas plastic with the chariot allegory, the sun allegory and especially the cave allegory,
but his great
political vision of the ideal state with a
philosopher queen at the top is also presented
in the one
with the most important quotes